es una recta final marcada por
escándalos y denuncias en la noche del
miércoles al jueves la revista semana
hizo públicos unos vídeos que muestran
discusiones entre miembros de la
compañía de gustavo petro hablan de
estrategias políticas para atacar y
desacreditar a sus rivales y dividir a
la colisión centrista la gran perdedora
de la primera vuelta en twitter como en
el terreno petro denunció un escándalo
de espionaje y aseguró que si se prueba
algún delito en los vídeos filtrados
renunciaría a su campaña ya están en
manos de la prensa horas y horas de esas
grabaciones a través de la plataforma de
colombia' humana
no asuste ni 5 porque lo que planteamos
allí es lo mismo que planteamos aquí es
el deseo de miles de personas de
construir un cambio social la compañía
ya se había puesto tensa para el
candidato de izquierda cuando en mayo su
oficina denunció un presunto complot de
una bondad para asesinarlo llevando a la
cancelación de sus actos en la región
cafetera del país su opositor en la
segunda vuelta el populista rodolfo
hernández dijo que los vídeos filtrados
son evidencia de corrupción y a su vez
denunció supuestos planes para matarlo
con cuchillos desde la ciudad de miami
en eeuu el candidato anunció la
suspensión de sus actividades públicas
en colombia tengo informaciones sobre
acciones que están planeando para más
adelante
ejecutarlas la verdad nunca me había
dado miedo ahora sí lo tengo y yo creo
que con sobradas razones sin embargo
horas después hernández anunció que
finalmente regresará el sábado a
colombia tras obtener garantía por parte
del gobierno pero asistirá de manera
virtual a su mitin previsto el mismo día
en vota se viene una última semana de
campaña electoral con las redes sociales
como arena ya que el ingeniero todavía
se rehúsa a asistir a debates las
encuestas siguen mostrando un empate
técnico entre los candidatos que
prometen cambio para colombia